yeah I fell on my old drug dealer which
right uh we thought we'd be like what
three no doc Hollywood okay where we
always talk we talk once a month but we
talk extrav around the Super Bowl some
about talk I'm talking I'm talking and
he gets off the phone and whatever
loading on wins I call him back and
we're talking and that morning I wake up
I'm thinking about I'm like how many
years do I know this [ __ ] this
relationship started by having getting
beat up and we given him a gun I stole
from 14 for it was a piece that was been
an old piece in the apartment it was a
38 and and I and I yeah it was a top
shelf and that gave that to them for
protection plus not bought me like ten
bags of blow from and they say yes just
to keep me alive I gave you a gun give
me a couple [ __ ] bindles here
yeah that relationships belong since
nineteen i'ma buy I was buying coking
them but now we've been friends since
yet and in 97 Wow
that's how long I know those brothers
fall yeah so 97 I was [ __ ] with that
yeah and I'm tacky old friends with them
today and what I did to them
I used to torture him oh yeah I used to
tell him come to the store
here we go Mick Jagger's here ah James
Brown is here this is if they snort coke
there here there get on down here
[ __ ] I'm lying well nothing
nothing you also had a lot of
credibility because you have some new
Bobby buggin Brown and Whitney Houston
the line is legit that was no no but
they never came to the store no no no
but they I kept that completely that
only even knew here existed but it was
funny how that I would get this
particular guy down there because I
always owed him a thousand bucks yeah he
go one we're going to come down to you
owe me money you got my money
[ __ ] I got um I got a 15 dollar check
for you but I'm telling you to come down
here because you could sell a [ __ ]
help starting everybody's here Rick
James is here Rick James that he's here
I'm telling ya I just saw
looking for [ __ ] package I would make
him go down there I would make him go
down looking for Lulu I would make him
go down there and he would go where's
all the drug news or is everybody I go
they just left
hey boy I got you give me a 62 come on
and I'll just stop sir I really strictly
nearly times I did that song are you
serious you were bring a ha I would make
him come down at 1:00 in the morning Tom
that Lisa assays with a [ __ ] sack a
hundred stock a hundred to [ __ ] who
are nobody even if I just held on to
that one skinny dude just give him a
tour here you throw a 20 that's better
than none when you get called on to that
60 til tomorrow
hey guys should happen the producers
going tomorrow I gotta go back I got a
little on your boy Dean Haley you wait
for the mailman to come and [ __ ] so tell
Lee that we knew the mailman by first
name little Filipinos oh my god yes
giving them reefer we damn well day okay
we're outside of our private company he
would tell me if I had a check yeah like
an hour before you go I got it I have
checked and again I'm back them and
polygon me
you heard the [ __ ] guy yeah yeah not
only at that time because a big check
for $3 or could have been a check for
$3,000 nobody knew but in my mind it was
the 3,000 yeah dream hiring Lee you know
learn something right here what and I
would just $36 Jesus Christ I'm a long
way away from 3G we'll make it work then
we cash this check at the Wilcox yeah
that means they take a dollar 50 I still
got 23 and changing I can still stop
stop by my buddies get a 20 spot I still
got three dollars for Gump is that any
who's gonna have the $2 word tip for one
of the comedy stuff and then yeah man we
would set out we knew that guy so well I
mean we just be sure not their pimp II
would be playing around and this was way
before prepared was it so Philippi yeah
this is what we know we still knew these
mailman I got mail there till 2005 what
yeah easy when did you move out when did
he move in and make any move it
explained love it
he's just having a doggone say here yes
well la was on the road who ever then
come home that the door was open there
was always a bigger than a cigarette
something something was going to happen
in that [ __ ] building if we had this
alive for two or three years